yeah hello
and welcome to this uh video yeah in
this blitz game
i was a little bit irritated by my
screen setup but i think it's fine
rogen the rogen lola roller
no probably not doing this right
um so symmetrical english black now has
a
choice there e6 knight c6
g6 b6 d5
knight c6 okay go e3
and yeah we get a line that i think
okay now d6 um was on
on the channel just like two days ago
this is not considered to be that great
for black as you can
certainly imagine that getting the
knight
pushed back cannot be ideal so
what i'm getting now is basically a
benoni
where i'm a tempo up
knight a6 yeah so i think i'm castling
him
sometimes a consideration if you want to
do that
okay just normal development should be
good
focus on the e5 brake potentially
um yeah well black's not really going to
go
b5 here right
um let's think about this for a moment
a6 a4 b6
yeah well he can probably push it push
it through
if he really wants to do it it's not
it's not something that worries me all
that much
so a6 a4 b6
something like that going to go a4 he
should probably consider b6
now to stop me from playing a5 so
he doesn't stop me okay so i will do
that
and now he has this slightly
damaged pawn structure on the queen side
the question is how i want to set up on
the queen side
i can play something like
rook a3 b3 pile up on that a
pawn or i can simply ignore this
it's also possible rook a3 that's
probably queen to b8
not sure if i want to invest this time
with prophylactics on the queen side
tough to say i will do it i'm not sure
about this
queen b8 rook b1 then b3
it looks a little bit maybe this is too
prophylactic
i'm just playing this um
basically saying that um your
structure is bad anyway so i'm just
going to
make sure the structure keeps um
yeah stays exactly as it is
but it's low it's slow and it's not so
yeah
it doesn't have a punch really okay so
i can take here and then take d6 why is
that
not possible that would be an
interesting question
why is this not possible
i mean i'm also fine after bishop e3 but
if i take it probably the knight will
take bishop d6 what is the tactic there
knight d4
maybe but i'm attacking the rook
so rook d8 or what's the deal i don't
get it
i don't get it or is there a tactic
based on the loose knight
takes knight takes bishop d6
like at the end some some 98 or
something is really odd
i don't see it i just wonder the time is
really ticking down
okay come on maybe this is this is
chicken chest yeah in some way
i couldn't quite see why i couldn't take
it it just looked a little bit loose
it's just like this position is just
better for white anyway so
it's kind of um
in some way um a moot point
so not a moot point but let's say this
is pragmatic decision that
is it's not um
not totally awful i think so
he wants to take on a4 right
i'm going to prepare bishop d2
and for some
concession by this rook
now i probably should have taken this
really okay i'm just very very cautious
yeah i don't want
sacrifice on h3 in
in this time situation
probably it was not a threat but
this is a three plus two it's important
to consider oh i totally blunted that
that friggin pawn ah
that's awful
[Music]
wow it's really awful
given that black's position was so bad i
just blundered the pawn
wow that's that's that's not
a good way to start the session
in 92 i overlooked knight e2
d4
knight c4 i cannot play ah this is this
is really bad
i think it's quite funny is that even
though i blundered
multiple moves the position is still not
totally clear
knight c4 is a threat is a threat
and even something like rook b1 after
rook trade i'm also okay
if i get to c4 this is
probably interesting this one and then
rook takes
and then i have the check at the end
okay
my idea is knight c4 and if he takes
bishop takes a5 is i think dropping
at the end of the day he's stuck with
those two non pieces
on c7 and h6 and g7 i'm sorry
does he have a big choice there i mean
if i get knight c4 and this is
also not great okay
give me
gift me the pawn
he cannot take i guess
the time is not so nice here of course
but
with increment things are a little bit
simpler you don't have to worry about
totally silly time losses
okay now i could actually uh take here
and then
play a5 at the end bishop e7 even
if i predicted a6 bishop d8 i'm just too
fast right
too fast
yeah i was a bit weird this game i mean
i played badly
i should never have some kind of trouble
because
black's position was just pretty awful
but i made my i made my life
very difficult with silly decisions and
oversights
so bishop d7
okay e5 already seems to win the game
yeah that can happen e5
if he's absolutely not taking care about
e5 at all i'm a little bit surprised
that it is so
bad
yeah i mean why why is better that's not
not really a question but
plus two points something is is really a
lot
that's a lot um
so let's say yeah this is just not
working right i can take and rook a7
and black is just getting annihilated
yeah okay e5 already
i'm not playing dynamic uh dynamic chess
sometimes
a5 is of course good for white but not
as good
yeah and now again i can push e5 and
probably kill him
yeah as i mentioned i might play over
prophylactically here
i mean the resulting position again e5
is killing him but
the resulting position is definitely
good and
i mean no like plus one something so
black is kind of stuck
in his bad structure and now i can
i can take i mean i didn't see why i
couldn't but
it looked a little bit yeah i don't know
i was a little bit concerned that there
could be some kind of
tactic on that night well i couldn't see
anything but like knight d4 i can take
b8 i should probably just take it
it was a bit of a scary move but it's
kind of again
the position is so comfortably better
than
that i didn't feel so pressed yeah and
here there are the sacrifice on c5 i saw
that but
with the time getting down i didn't want
to do it
like this this is interesting because
the rook is stuck
and i have those mighty pawns
cannot even play a5 as i just take this
so this was definitely an
option but i what i did not see is
simply
with all my moves here
um that i was blundering a c4 that is
just
silly if i take with the rook i i
preserve
those structural advantages without any
problem
like this position is eternally better
for white
because of just um the additional space
that i have
is always stuck with weak pawns
potentially
and the knight on c7 is also really
having a hard time to find a good
a good spot this is just yeah 1.1 what
the engine is saying is kind of
um yeah adequate i would actually
think it's higher in particular in
practical terms
but i blundered c4 and that was making
things of course very problematic
92 still seems to be better for white
yeah i kind of panicked here only at 20
seconds
[Music]
and here the position is shaky
f5 here looks good now for black
now that looks like a very good choice
you have to activate anyway
and probably this is
causing me lots of problems
yeah now black has activated him this is
weak and so on that that probably would
have killed me
i mean objectively anyway yeah we see
that the engine says it's winning but
it's impossible also probably to defend
us in a real game
so yeah now i'm i'm just toast here in
this position
okay rook b3
yes now rook b3 was of course better
the point is that he cannot take because
of the check
and this idea with the maid look at it
made coming
that was a lot better i didn't see it
it's not it's not really difficult it's
just like i had absolutely no time
like 20 seconds and okay i played this
one
and now knight b5 was killing which is
yeah it's nice if the engine shows it to
you but it's pretty difficult
if you have a blitz game in front of you
but what he did is certainly okay and
knight d4 is also a large advantage
bishop d3 a5
and rook c1 yeah and now this is not
clear this is not clear at all s9 c4 is
coming
and after knight b3 i have this move
rook b1 and indeed i'm already much
better
even though i'm a pawn down yeah i mean
that's what i said with the
the bad structure the bad structure is
if i'm not um
um yeah if i'm not losing the house
this is still counting yeah that this is
all weak and the bad pieces
i i had one total totally silly
oversight
here i can just take this and win yeah
the rook is attacked and there is rook
b8 bishop h6
during the game i actually thought that
this would be better for me as well
which is
probably wrong i saw this line but he
has this c4
strike this is nice here
the knight has no squares but c4 is just
good
yeah i don't know if i would have
spotted that but
um yeah he he
took it and now this is just awful for
black
i'm surprised i mean the engine is not
very deep there on
22. i thought it could be higher
because if you drop the a pawn it might
be that you cannot stop the a pawn
white's a pawn i mean from promotion and
then the eval could be even higher
anyway it's it's much better for white
and um it's it seems that i didn't
make any ridiculous mistakes anymore
and i'd be yeah whatever i mean i think
this is just lost anyway
yeah and here just had to spot that
the bishop is stopping oops this bishop
is stopping both pawns
and this bishop is not coming around to
cover a7 in time so it's it's winning
yeah interesting game not clearly not
without mistakes
on on both parts but interesting thanks
for watching